as you were talking about like the
talking to one of the afghan soldiers
that you knew
and how he you know hey we're gonna stay
here we're gonna fight they'll never
take us
do you remember all that stuff that
happened up in portland when the antifa
took over the part of the yeah part of
the neighborhood or whatever they were
calling it i think it was originally
called chop and then they changed it to
jazz but it was the occupied zone or
something like this but somebody was
asking me about it
and i kind of said
hey there's no one up there in the chop
that's like ready to die for the cause
that's ready to say you know what we're
gonna stay here
they're just not there's not up there
there's no i mean america
and i kind of made the comment that hey
even the people that are antifa members
guess what they have cell phones and
they have you know like nice they have
clothing and they have running water and
it's just not that bad of a thing and
they're not right that committed to it
and
it's it's interesting when you think
about what it really takes
for someone to stand up and be willing
to sacrifice themselves for a cause
whatever that cause is and when you look
at the taliban and you you're this
afghan
person that's been fighting for however
many years and you've been fighting for
the americans you've been fighting for
the afghan government for 10 years or
seven years
and then you're like well
it looks like we're completely
surrounded
if i fight i'm gonna die or i can just
kind of put down my weapon take off my
uniform and carry on with my life
and i yeah and that was you know i
i think it was sort of the next day
joe biden came out and said
you know these guys ran away from their
posts and things and and to a degree i
understand where that came from but it
actually it upset me because
they were really sold out by their
leadership and and i'll give you
examples so saffy the guy that i met
that friday when i was finally able to
get back in contact with him after mazar
had fallen and i asked him are you okay
where are you
and he said you know he'd gone out that
day and and they just they were so
outnumbered and his three bodyguards had
been killed and
um you know it was really the commanders
that were trying to hold it and he said
by four o'clock that afternoon somebody
came to him and said oh dust and left
and so did the commando left like you're
your commander's left and it's up to you
if you want to stay and die or you can
leave and he just
he they were sold out by everybody
i i did hear stories um from guys that i
knew
that said
that the taliban would like approach a
village yep and just send a messenger in
there and be like hey you know here's
your chance we know you were you know
you we know you're afghan security um
you can put down your guns and be cool
or we're gonna kill everyone and guys
were like uh okay we're surrounded we're
gonna die um i guess we'll just
yeah go back to the way it used to be by
the way that's the other thing it was
they have sort of a lot of them had
memory of what it used to be like and
it's like okay well i guess
we're going back the way it used to be
but it's better to do that be alive than
be dead
and the amount of sacrifices that a lot
of those afghan soldiers made i mean
they don't they won't even release the
number of killed but it's
it's well past 100 000. yeah i mean
there was at least 50 000 killed going
into
this whole thing taking place yeah so
it's not like and again there's plenty
of
americans that fought alongside the
afghans and had met awesome afghan
troops just like in iraq you know there
was and
by the time you were in iraq and the app
the iraqis were fighting isis they were
taking massive casualties massive
casualties
going to take mosul back that was led by
the iraqi forces and they took massive
casualties and they kept going compared
to in in the battle of ramadi the iraqi
forces were
some of them were very scared and didn't
want to take lead and definitely didn't
want to take casualties we had whole
battalions abandon and leave
so
that idea of
this kind of
this kind of clear-cut american version
of the way things are
is doesn't apply here there's no
clear-cut
way of
hey
oh if you get if you're an american you
get captured we know what's gonna happen
you're gonna get tortured you're getting
killed it's like hey you're an afghan
security force and you
surrender
you're not sure what's gonna happen but
you know what's gonna happen if you
don't surrender you're gonna die
so
and then you see your leadership
or running away all running away all of
them
and every single one of them ran away
including the president including the
president yeah including the president
who
yeah with that guy that is a is an
insane situation i mean you have that
guy ashraf ghani who
who is like a professor at berkeley a
professor at johns hopkins
uh went to some leadership school at
harvard
wrote the book called fixing failed
states which is like an academic
exploration of this stuff theoretical
it's an embarrassment yeah and he bailed
with a bunch of money by the way and and
yeah a bunch of money is now under
investigation but what what i remember
going back in being afghanistan in 2017
and sort of hearing when i'd go to the
the nato compound of the us embassy and
everyone would say all these great
things about ghani and i remember saying
to a few people have you gone out to the
street just to talk to the afghan people
because they have a different idea you
know so i think part of that problem was
the us because nobody was leaving that
base in the diplomacy world they were
getting a vacuum of information that was
pre-approved people to enter they were
all part of this sort of puppetry stream
and they weren't actually out there
talking to the afghans who were terribly
frustrated with the corruption going on
terribly frustrated with the sort of i
guess the the pashtun and the
sectarianism and things and it just
the picture that was was so warped
compared to the reality that i saw even
back then